hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey hey
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is are you garbage folks it's a
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians
we found out they grew up classy or if
they're absolute trash
i'm your host states foley coming at you
on a glorious day
i'm down here in totty's basement guess
who didn't come home last night
hoodie tony where's she at she's
shacking up with this assistant manager
from wawa
all right who's maybe a year older than
me i told him i ain't calling him uncle
pete i'll tell you that right now
so we'll see how it all works out sure
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me
folks if you ever want to do a ted talk
how to move cheap playing cards
this is the [ __ ] guy right here cause
he sold him out in 24 hours
and we love you and we love him i'm
gonna start calling you mr ryan right
now
give it up for kippy kevin james ryan
hey gang what's up thanks for tuning in
the boss is here [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
thanks for tuning in also thanks to
cards
the ayg playing guard sold out in
[ __ ] like what do we call like 12
hours
not too shabby by the way all sales
final
six to 10 business weeks for shipping
and nobody said you were actually to
receive said cars you bought the
idea of a deck of ayg playing cards
there is one pack left and they're
sitting right there
if anybody wants to purchase the display
model
hit me on the dms don't he's going to
try to auction this all for sure don't
take it
you know pull up in a lambo next week uh
guys thanks so much for tuning in
always uh as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube those
numbers are what true to [ __ ]
roof uh also patreon.com are you garbage
you can sign up you get bonus episodes
of ayg you get episodes of hard feelings
we got them you want them and then for
the top tier patrons every week
uh i'm sorry once a month we'll play ayg
with you guys you ask us questions we
ask you questions
we have a couple of beers it's a good
[ __ ] time good time on the zoom there
yeah it's awesome
check it out guys thanks for tuning in
good time thank you everybody for the
cards we really appreciate it we love
you guys
and we want to give a nice shout out to
our producer extraordinaire
folks let me tell you how we do it okay
we start with an ice
english muffin we toasted golden brown
what yeah then what do you do
two slices of american cheese and a big
old
sausage and that's how you get to t-bone
mcmuffin give it the [ __ ] up
for the magic man toby mcmullen
what's up toby mcmuffin today i got two
masks on like pain
can't turn into michael jackson over
there huh a little propofol whatever
it's called
anyway gang we could not be more excited
to have our incredibly special guests
here with us today
i've been with them since jump street
update all the time i know here in new
york city known this guy a long time
crawled out of the [ __ ] village with
this kid used to work a crew down there
at the village lantern yeah he's an
earner too
very no he ain't no [ __ ] street dog
nope he's a worker
very funny very successful podcaster
comedian and actor he's been featured on
mtv vulture comedy central also a writer
been a contributing writer for the npr
hit wait wait
don't tell me of course he's the co-host
of the asian not asian podcast fantastic
podcast
he's a cool kid cool he's one of the
cool guys he's a cool kid
he dresses cool even his [ __ ]
headphones right now are cool right now
i would have never thought to do that
well he doesn't want to mess up his
doesn't want to mess up the [ __ ]
clock
looks like steve aoki over here i like
it
no i don't google
hey it'll work keep it moving all right
he dresses cool i don't know where he
gets his clothes but i can tell you what
they don't come in my size jump in his
own merch by the way which is a [ __ ]
pro move
i was going to wear a clean living shirt
damn
this kid's we got asian not asian hats
on all of a sudden we're like what the
[ __ ] i'm biting his podcast cards next
what's going on ladies and gentlemen
give it up for the very funny
boomy obey everybody hey thank you so
much for having me
oh thanks for coming dude this is
amazing man happy to happy to have you
love it good to see you buddy we start
we were down we worked at a crew down in
the village
absolutely that's where we started you
make it sound like we were knocking over
banks we were telling shitty jokes
great second story man right here we
worked at a crew back in the day before
all this [ __ ] blew over
shut up we stunk back in the day what is
the uh the origin story
of fumi you're a suburban kid i'm sorry
for bourbon cake
oh not enough from columbus suburbs i
mean
for arguments i was [ __ ] dead on with
cleveland okay
he didn't say wisconsin give it to him
yeah it was called uh
hilliard i'm sure you guys have
listeners in ohio i know for sure we got
a show coming up in ohio oh do you
really
yeah over there i can't announce it yet
oh okay oh [ __ ]
i did ketamine with my friend's dad and
hillyard really
yeah was it fumi's now he was never home
it makes sense
i was out wandering the streets you're
kidding me and you did ketamine oh [ __ ]
yeah drink blood like platinums how old
are you like sickly like 40.
what's happening we got to start the
vetting process over again with this guy
this kid's a little shitty bones on
goofball [ __ ] jessie pikman over
there i don't like it
yeah man so i i moved to where i was
eight from japan but i like
basically spent hold on go back oh you
were born in japan i was born in japan
parents are japanese these are japanese
born in japan or german
which is why you have an interesting
guest and a podcast
you were born in japan japan yeah yeah
yeah
where in japan uh it's this prefecture
or state called chiba which is next to
tokyo it's like the new jersey of japan
it's like
tokyo old school i like it yes i'm from
there but you know i was so young when i
[ __ ] really remember
yeah and so like my first real memories
and stuff it's all it's all
central i hate you don't remember no i
remember i mean like in the basement
yeah i mean i'm sure if we can pull like
a birthday party or something but he
doesn't
remember going to school everything he
can find a wawa over there baby yeah
yeah
but uh yeah so move to ohio when i was
eight and then why ohio
uh my dad like just some business [ __ ]
like
his company he basically builds
factories for cars and there's like a
honda factory in
ohio wait hold on hold on yes he owns a
company that builds
car factory he doesn't own he just works
for one anytime someone says their dad
does something foley's got to break down
the organizational structural chart of
the corporation
i said you're telling me your dad owns
new jersey because i can i can hear my
mom
i can hear my mom's so his father makes
cause
i can hear him yeah it's like you're so
shocked that he has a job or something
so he works for a company that builds
car car factory it's pretty good yeah so
like that's not a community
engineer or something yeah something
like that uh and then there's like a
weird japanese pocket in ohio because
there's a honda factor
sure so it's all a bunch of like weird
white kids and then like a pocket of
japanese kids but when i'm just school
because my parents didn't want me to
speak
japanese at school so i could learn
english faster they sent me to like
a little like a school district that
wasn't as good as the other as
wow because all the asian families just
want to go to send their kids to the
best school
yeah so i went to school hard knocks
yeah that's a multiple that had to be a
little rough coming up
rough man really yeah i mean i
i guess when you're younger like you
don't really not too progressive out
there from what i understand no i mean
but you know like when you're young you
don't know and you're an immigrant you
don't know what trashy is so like
i mean i don't know that i would call
myself trashy i had like there's a lot
of trashy people around me
sure i identify so hold on when you got
here you spoke
japanese right right as much as an
eight-year-old enough yes
um no english did your parents speak
english
uh like a little bit but you know you
pick it up as a kid you know because
so you're rolling in first day of school
yeah don't speak
english a bunch of [ __ ] weird-looking
white kids with weird haircuts
yeah damn that's kind of i remember like
i brought
because you know like asian people super
like stationary [ __ ] like i brought my
life
pencil case that's a stereotype he said
it not us yeah
i want that on record you know how we
love trafficking right
i brought my like little pencil case
with like a little anime characters
like the first day of school they're top
shelf man yeah and they're like
roasted but like i didn't understand
what they were saying yeah but i knew it
was like no this shit's cool dude i
wouldn't say you got
those those are racial slurs that's not
fun loving jeff ross stuff on
comedy there's no creativity in ching
chong yeah yeah yeah yeah they were
being mean kids
yeah yeah yeah so a lot of that a lot of
that but you know uh when you're like
really like second to third grade it was
like it was pretty chill i mean i think
the kids that age don't really
understand like you didn't know what
yeah they're just hanging out
they don't really understand but it was
like around fourth grade fifth grade
when you start liking girls that's when
that's when like that [ __ ] kind of kicks
in because that's when the competition
comes in the competition
exactly so they're gonna you know they
gotta knock you off a spot or whatever
so
it's [ __ ] yeah there's a lot of that
i mean i remember like uh
i'm trying to say this without being sad
but like
legit like i remember in middle school
high school some of my like
good friends had me in their phones as
so my full name is masafumi right
they had me in their phones as masa
ching chong i
swear and i was just like yeah they're
funny like i didn't even know
it was insane and i think about that i
was a 30 year old man that's toxic
it was a different
[Laughter]
did you call like the irish kid potato
steve or whatever
yeah got him hey ricka tony rick get
over here
i mean they called me roly-poly foley
for most of my life
i mean it's a name you really lived you
really grew into
what about brothers and sisters uh i got
a little sister how old how much younger
she's only a year younger than me okay
so you guys are kind of in this together
exactly but it's a little bit easier on
girls i feel like people are not gonna
say racist [ __ ] to like girls faces i
don't know if that makes sense but like
it's just i i feel like it's a little
bring it around no this is this is why
i'm interested in this when i was a kid
i moved uh
i was probably yeah maybe eight or nine
years old i moved from upstate
pennsylvania down to the suburbs
of philly and i'm not a strong person as
we know i'm pretty shallow under weak on
the inside
that was a huge thing to me just being
in a new school and i spoke the language
so i'm so fascinated with the fact like
if you drop me off at [ __ ] 10 at a
[ __ ] school in tokyo
i would have [ __ ] i would have
crumbled
i would have shitty godzilla
the embassy had to get involved like
they got tanks and [ __ ] like
they build a robot version of me to
fight me
that's a game show right there man you'd
be famous no i'm just saying like that
that i mean that's that's that's a
[ __ ] that's an obstacle man sure but
like i
stayed in the same district from for 10
years so like by the end like you know i
say
obviously there were some weird habits
were there other japanese kids in your
school when you got there because
they sent you to it like very few but a
lot of them would just like move back
and then by the time i got to high
school we had some kids who just
moved from japan to there
but like by that time like i was only
away yeah yeah
i'm not teasing them but like they were
just like four definitely just so
foreign you're so you're so like
american you know yeah
they're the ones like with the anime
pencil case now you know what i'm saying
you know so you got a ford f-150 oh yeah
i got a stroller not from around here
are you boy
get in the truck oj did it bumper
sticker on your thing
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so what was the
so now so you what was the town like
that you grew up in because you said
how do you send a kid to another public
school in a different way
no no we we so we like chose to live
there so central ohio is pretty small so
there's like
districts like dublin or arlington which
are a little bit like more classier and
their schools are really good
but we specifically moved to hilliard so
that i could go to school
that's like an immigrant parent yeah
yeah like you're gonna
yeah yeah they wanted me to fight that's
tough [ __ ] yeah but i mean it's like
it's like a white suburbs like big
football town everybody's really into
football
and that's all you got out there yeah
yeah yeah and then like a lot of like
class divide
so like we had you know i don't know
it's like in philly where you guys grew
up but like
depending on so there's like this main
road right yeah the school's here i live
here
there's all these neighborhoods right
and then like they're called like river
landings or whatever
and then like the closer you got to the
school like the shittier they got
you know wow yeah yeah like that's about
right it was crazy i mean like the
the disparity was like just so shocking
but no yeah that's similar similar to
where i grew up there was always like
this like one
road where you'd be like driving down
and like you would be driving down
it's like the nicer neighborhoods or
whatever like the nicer part of town
and then as you got to the shittier end
of the town there was more and more
people
walking along like the highway yeah you
should be walking on you know what i
mean
yeah yeah there's just more like
shopping carts flipped over and stuff it
just got a little grittier that's a big
towel you got highway walkers
there's no whole foods folks
don't ask anybody for the trader joe's
is yeah um
what did i want to ask you so but you so
your dad
you guys had a little bit of cash i'd
have to assume right like a little bit
but like my dad
central ohio cash i know but still i
mean he owns a [ __ ]
car plant that makes car plants for the
rest of your life
he's going to tell people yeah he
invented buildings for god's sakes
um yeah i mean did your mom work or no
no she couldn't work because she didn't
have a
like we weren't citizens i wasn't a
citizen until 2015. so none of us could
work
right right and dirty yeah i like it
legal yeah
yeah yeah um but yeah i mean holy [ __ ]
yeah we i mean
i know we play like middle class but
like my friends range from like rat tail
go-kart to like
to like i was a rat town car kid yeah
that to like i'm going to yale next year
you know what i'm saying like it was
just like oh suburbs has that
you know i know it's beautiful it's like
mechanics kids mingling with lawyers
kids yeah i got everybody mixing it up
it's [ __ ] fantastic now did you fall
into the
to the redneck trap a little bit the
trap uh i mean i think the the kid i
was really close with since like fourth
grade he was like a little trashy and i
just tried to stick with him
for like until high school um he had
some i mean he wasn't like poor or
anything but like
he just like he had like he was one of
those kids who like a german he bought
his family bought a german shepherd but
like couldn't afford to train it
like what like having those things off
the leash it's insane
it is like that's not a dog you just let
wrong don't look him in the eye man
those guys are nervous yeah and then
like we got a gun with no safety
yeah yeah it's like getting a gun and
not going to the range
just letting it hang out on the counter
for an hour
um yeah i don't know like his mom was
super into like sweepstakes i remember
that that was like a thing
yeah yeah but like she would winch it
like she won like a mustang
and then like she lost her dignity
though for sure creativity
and gene walking away with that you have
a friend whose mom won a mustang yes
that's how i know he's kind of trashy
because he's telling us about that
but then like she won her thing she was
like proud of it you know and i mean
you know it was i met a chick like that
at a bar one time we were it was when
you could still smoke inside i asked her
for a light and she's like can i borrow
your cell phone and i'm like for what
lady
she's like i gotta call into wmg right
now
i'm really good at winning radio
contests last week i won two tickets to
foghorn i'ma get out of here oh
man that is [ __ ] garbagio
uh you and your sister went to the same
school though yeah yep yep
okay all right where'd your dad go to
school in
tokyo what do you want to know though
it could be some incredible institution
what was the meal plan like at that
storm authority
did your dad go out much do they take
transfer students
do they they have an international
program i'm getting a picture i imagine
your dad's a pretty sharp guy
yeah he's pretty he's pretty smart but
like he was just i just remember he was
always gone
on like business trips for like a long
time and for a while the nice part of
um he would just come home like once a
month for a long long time
what and then and that doesn't add up
you know that right oh of course not
for for sure i've got a half brother
sister the plant was in town
no like he so he so for a little bit he
was working in ohio and then like that
project would end and then he would go
to like kentucky or oh okay that makes
it right so
i mean i don't think he was lying about
the actual job sure but like maybe the
time
away he wasn't he was like yeah we gotta
i gotta get an apartment i don't know he
didn't ask us to move with him i don't
know it was weird
well which i kind of respect because
he's like oh you guys have you're
already integrated into this life sure
yes yeah community you have friends and
stuff like that makes sense to me
guys seems like a straight jew wait he
had an apartment somewhere else
uh when he lived in south carolina he
did i remember we visited him a couple
of times but like it was
it was just weird because i remember
he'd cut he would come home more weird
imagine visiting your dad he's still
with your mom
yeah can we visit dad this weekend
did you have room did he have rooms
there for you like one of the places he
like
lived with a co-worker or something yeah
i don't know man how hot was she
it was a dude let me ask you this i
probably should have asked this in the
beginning
i thought this one was going to be a
no-brainer but it turns out i'm
wrong do you think you're garbage
uh i think i have garbage taste but i
don't think i was raised
he did roll in with [ __ ] two
sandwiches from mcdonald's and eight on
antoine's table
before the recording i honestly i don't
know how you're coming back from my
dad's roommates
i'm being dead honestly that's a tough
one that's a tough one
that's a tough one if my roommates
you get your [ __ ] and get out um was
your dad would you how would you
describe was your dad like a good
dresser
or was it was he like put together at
all or was he like nah he was pretty
like
regular really quiet like he's
definitely hiding something for sure
wow but like because he was never home
the times he
what would come home by the time i was
like older like 16
i didn't i feel like i didn't know him
as well and then he would still hit me
he would hit him beat up by a dude in
the neighborhood
that's like getting in a bar fight i
remember he hit me once and i was like
who are you
i started laughing i was like i don't
know you man i don't even know your
middle name man
hey steve you're going to be in south
carolina not going to go home and beat
my kids this weekend
he hit you gets back in the car
[Laughter]
hey kid where are the towels you talk
like that too i don't know why
[Laughter]
which one you use for me
the redneck the redneck kick it ain't me
man
he gets a slap too shut up boy
holy [ __ ] wow gang let's talk about a
good time we're having over there on the
old
stereo app oh yeah me and kippy over
there taking your calls every thursday
night at nine o'clock
yeah guys if you're not familiar it's a
good time a lot of good shows on there
we're on there
you can you call in you can leave a
voicemail we answer we play it on there
we have fun with it i might have a
couple of cocktails like i've been doing
guys get involved it's a good time check
it out go to stereo.com
kevin ryan the link will be in the bio
check it out it's free it's live it's
fun
do it gang let's face it making trips to
the post office is not the way you want
to be spending your time so we have an
alternative for you it's a new sponsor
here on the show and we love them
we're recommending stamps.com stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere
right from your computer send letters
ship packages and pay a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups
and more stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours
and tons of money with stamps.com you
get the service of the post office
and ups all in one place oh yeah all
right
big discounts mailing shipping rates
absolutely fantastic
yeah guys they do it all for you it's
really great they sent us a package we
signed up with them
uh we got a scale we got a printer and
we're sending out all of our merch
uh the are you garbage card game yep
sending that all out
in from antoidi's basement it's easy
peasy
it's they do it all for you they take
out all the hassle it's awesome
i couldn't stress it anymore if you're a
small business owner get involved with
stamps.com
if tony can do it you can do it and they
take all the hassle out for you it's
fantastic
um you get discounts up to 40 off post
office rates and 62 percent
off of ups shipping rates what's there
not to love about
wetting your beak a little bit
unbelievable you know what i mean not to
mention stamps.com is a fraction of the
cost
of those expensive posted shipping
meters they give you a chance to scale
for cheap you get it on the low plus
they give you
you know a couple of credits when you
sign up good company so stop wasting
time by going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk
and with our promo code garbage baby
that's what we're talking about garbage
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale to give you right
off the cuff crazy you know
wha wha wha why would you not do this
what's that promo code again
garbage g-a-r-b-a-g-e
i think i spelled that right no
long-term commitments or contracts maybe
just like we like you gotta be able to
stick and move that's right just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the home page
type in garbage g-a-r-b-a-g-e
that stamps.com promo code garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
oh yeah now back to the show they were
hitters though i like that
uh yeah i think a lot of immigrant
families tend to be it's a little more
uh
mine for some reason
i don't i i never didn't deserve it i'll
tell you that right now
i mean they were yeah it was like
abusive i don't know that's nice no i
got you
you
[Laughter]
i didn't mean to spill the chocolate
milk it was my fault find out his dad's
actually my dad
the photo that wasn't a fat white guy in
blue bell pennsylvania
love that man this is a hot one baby
damn
that is something else and what about
yours you say your sister kind of
coasted through
were you guys tight you had to be tight
um you know it was like i was one of
those things where like we were too
close in age in high school to be
tight and she you're older she's younger
she's
one grade younger than me
exactly there were a couple years when
she was like dating people in my grave
that's
and now it doesn't matter you know but
like back then it was just like
no no this entire grade is mine sure
yeah yeah yeah that's all you got you
only have your great yeah it's only
guys that could beat you up no they were
just like [ __ ] weird dudes
i don't know but like you could hear
[ __ ] about the stuff they did and i was
like a virgin you know
what what is what is fingering you know
like wait really yeah
like my sister was definitely doing all
that stuff before i was um and that was
like the weirdest part i think because
my mom
or one time like i'm listening he keeps
asking about my sister
one time my mom caught my little sister
like
having sex with her like white boyfriend
or something and she's like i flipped
out
wait a minute hold on flipped out lights
a little bit
yo she flipped out this is in high
school high school yeah but i was a
senior she was a junior so i don't know
it's not
too weird so were you kind of were you
kind of more straight and narrow when
she was a little bit no i was horny as
hell bro but like yes
i don't know were you not were you
[ __ ] you guys [ __ ]
high school yeah were you really yeah
what the [ __ ] well this one's falling
forward's a good looking
oh no what what's uncle hank yeah i
didn't even know that i'm still not
[ __ ]
i wasn't getting beat up by some guy in
a cab i'll tell you that
but yeah well she caught him one time
and she freaked out and like as the
older son she like pulled me aside in
the house
yeah i wasn't home though and later she
was like my mom was like smoking i was
like you don't even smile
who are your parents dude this is a wild
story yeah unless she was like we gotta
talk and
i think she was scared a because
obviously you know somebody's [ __ ]
her daughter but also like he was not
the japanese and like just like the
language barrier and she's like
you know to her like a lot american kids
were like savages sure
big guys you know whatever right so she
was like uh
you know i gotta like i think i'm gonna
go over there like talk to this kid i'm
gonna go to his house and talk to him
he's like will you come with me
[Laughter]
how he's closing all over town how many
fingers man how's that work
jesus yeah yeah yeah damn yeah
and what does she do now she's like a
public health worker
so she does does good yeah she's great
your mom and dad are still together
they're still together still in the
house
nah they've this is so random they live
in mexico now
wow uh because my dad's just building
more [ __ ] over there it's hard to find i
don't even know if we can release it no
there's something shady going on with
with these obeys
are they retired no no no it's just like
you're still doing his job
yeah because there's actually like a lot
of there's cars in america i know yeah
yeah yeah yeah wow that is
so my dad was because he's like very
smart but my mom is actually like if i'm
garbage it's i get it from her she's
blue collar
like my were they were they like were
they class wise differently like was
your dad from like a yeah i remember
like
mom uh my dad's family like a little
more buttoned up but he has more
relatives who went to like good schools
my grandmother like that's pretty good
that's gonna be carrying one on the pod
write that down
cut that out so no one knows who said it
that just couldn't be a kippy that
pulled you out of the roommate
buttoned up it's nice yeah but my mom's
size like none of her siblings went to
college
my mom went for a little bit um my
mom my grandmother she passed recently
but when she died it turned out she was
she was doing insurance fraud like holy
[ __ ]
i don't know if that's garbage or not
but uh it ain't classy dude
like that like jump in front of the car
and stuff like that no no she
sold insurance but like she would sell
it to like me
and my sister who didn't even live here
just to get her white collar thank you
yeah she ain't out there with a knife
for nothing yeah yeah yeah yeah white
collar crying
no she's dead was it like was it like a
lot of money or just like
i got corners and you know i i don't
know this was like
but like i just thought like because all
my friends when their
grandparents like they get money so when
she died i was like am i gonna get money
so i caught my aunts and uncles and
they're like now we actually owe the
government money
i don't even know how it's possible we
got three months of community service
yeah between
your mom just randomly smoking one day
your dad who you don't know hitting you
and your criminal grandmother this is
shaping up to be
treasured yeah dude i was not expecting
this yeah dude
that haircut really fools you
[Laughter]
your family really took moving to ohio
seriously
[ __ ] blend in holy [ __ ]
yeah quick do a slip and fall bang a
football player
i'm moving to south carolina and getting
a roommate
if anybody asks i own a car dealership
yeah go go
that's probably why they didn't want me
to go to school with other japanese kids
trying to
find them to find the jig is up all the
other japanese family in the area were
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
holy these people are [ __ ] nuts man i
was all the way here to just to
[ __ ] just go into pieces i was not
expecting this i was yeah nice quiet you
know what i mean we moved to ohio um
all right let's see let's get into some
[ __ ] questions here we're cooking
already uh
since we're kind of on the topic a
little bit what'd you get on your sats
you're a smart kid i think about this
is he i don't know i'm not uh wait so
wait what'd you get on your sat okay
two subject or three subject two subject
you're just making this up no no when i
took it there was a third subject yeah
what was the writing subject then they
were
writing yeah but they got rid of it okay
so this is out of rude 1800
1600 yeah uh 13 10. it's not bad
it's not bad that's buttoned up put it
in put it out
it's actually really good but everything
you just told me in the last 10 minutes
one i don't know if i believe you
[Laughter]
brought me out of your wallet i know
your grandmother could have been giving
you the test
what did i get or what did my grandma
get
my grandma got a 33 out of 1600 i don't
know
what'd your sister get do you remember i
don't know like a maybe a little lower i
think all right yeah
there you go got her back for that um
what'd you guys get ooh
come on i got by the way this is like a
very sensitive question to ask an asian
person so i'm glad i can talk with you
guys
thirteen hundreds good for anybody how's
that fall in the asia thirteen hundreds
of oh that's low in the asia
hassan minhaj has this joke on his show
where he's like
he's like yeah i got a 1300 on my sats
and some girl
gasps because i know how low it is
like it's pretty age dude asian parents
it's wild
they would have had a parade in my town
if i would have got it you could have
taken it four times
combined that's it they took a 37 parter
and not gotten
that's an amazing score thank you so
much that was really good i assume you
go to any college you want if you get a
13.
no no no
[Laughter]
you take a peek at it
so where did you go to college i was nyu
for what
i studied music business and computer
science still
now okay now that's a little bit of cash
you got a good score in your scts you
went to a credit institution
here in the city that's not you
graduated i graduated yeah what was your
gpa when you graduated
i like of three five 3.5 it's great
that's great
okay that's really good what do you mean
great that's fantastic
but looking at a 275 over here this is
like until you haven't had an asian
person on your podcast
freaking out of the 3.5 what is
happening
pretty good it's not that it's i'm
telling you from the story that you just
told me you should be selling bait
somewhere but don't give me that
it's like vince gilligan wrote your
childhood
that's crazy that's [ __ ]
nyu 13 what 13 what 13 30 13 10.
long con grandmother yeah this guy's all
over the place i can't get a read on
them
it's like wallpaper um all right let's
do some of the basics uh
okay we can start with this what was the
name of the street that you grew up on
what was the name of it
okay trigger from mark twain drive and
there was a guy who i don't know if
that's classy or trash
there's a guy on my street i don't even
believe you're asian
a guy on my street who who makes a
living
selling mark twain like antiques or like
goods
and he bought his house selling a chair
that mark twain
used to write a book was mark twain from
ohio
no he's from the qs or something he was
just like super into who's mark twain
that's weird why was it why him
nothing why was that the name of your
street i don't know was it a coincidence
that this guy moved to mark twain no no
he bought it on purpose
okay yeah yeah yeah i wasn't sure if he
like moved there and was like you know
what
wait so start moving some of his mark
twain merchants he moved was it mark
twain street road what was it
drive drive driver mark twain he lived
on mark twain court which was like
connected but
that's pretty nice court drive not bad
it's pretty good
what are you guys dealing with place uh
i was i was
a road but i was it was a call we were
in a cul-de-sac so it was
it was pretty pretty classy i was away
i
[Laughter]
you know it's a real bad look in the
suburbs a numbered street that or a pipe
yeah
if you're on like butler pike or
something there's a median for sure
somebody got tagged crossing that street
i'll tell you that um
garage growing up what do you mean yeah
i had one
that you got i got a 13-10
[ __ ] garage you're talking to people
with all garages what is happening
your sister was going through the
basketball team like like the garage
insult you
all right did you have a refrigerator in
that garage uh no
no i think some of the families well the
for your family is bananas i'm picking
up on
to me the garage refrigerator was trashy
because all my friends who had it had
the
like the freeze pop things from walmart
yeah that's all they had in it yeah and
i used to think that that was all you
need kids
that's it
a couple of loose miller miller genuine
drafts and you're good
they are they're they're trash but we've
gone over it a bunch they're trash by
nature
but it's you know it's celebrated here
it ain't hoodies that's but they're by
nature they're class
did you hang out in the walmart parking
lot as like a social hang
yes it wasn't always walmart but it'd be
like
whatever you know yeah eagle was like a
supermarket like something i mean
because there were there's like
literally nowhere to go
i remember a couple times we would like
hang out like we would like sneak
the church was open like at night the
doors were open so we just like go in
there and hang out like everybody's
doing hail mary's and stuff
like it was like we literally anywhere
where there aren't parking lots i know
we weren't getting laid
when they fried it up going to st
[Laughter]
all right i got a couple questions for
you here um just a couple general
general questions um what'd you
what was it usually your lunch growing
up and school
would you buy would you bag would your
mom make you something what was the deal
sometimes i would make something but it
was just like a regular sandwich
um but i would buy a lot at school okay
um
the school had like i was a big fan
remember you guys are like bosco sticks
you guys ever have that
no it was like it's basically like
uh it's like breadsticks at olive garden
except there's cheese in
inside oh and you dip it into the pizza
yeah is that a midwest thing yeah sticks
that was pretty big i'd get that a lot
it's a stuffed cheesy bread
uh yeah but the like cheese wasn't
actual cheese
and it would like the it's it's
the thing it was known for is that it
would like get stuck in your throat oh
it's like a big gum
a lot of people choke on it but i got
that a lot they look pretty good though
yeah
wait so your school sold them yeah yeah
yeah we called them bosco sticks i don't
know if they're if they were proper boss
yeah yeah yeah i doubt it yeah yeah as
sad as it sounds
the way the school's shelling out for
name-brand possibly
not happening malio string but like i
don't know like uh uh what was it called
like those taco balls bowls or whatever
we had those
that's pretty good pizzas yeah did you
play any sports growing up were you
involved in
yeah uh cross country lacrosse
there you go yes and then one year i
quit cross-country marching band so
wow what'd you play in the marching band
trumpet did you were you playing the
whole time or you just randomly picked
it up and started playing
i was playing the whole time i just i
didn't want to do it when i was a
freshman because it's like nerdy
it really sets the course of your high
school career if you're
i'd say that was a lateral move yeah
that was it was co-ed though it was one
of the reasons why i did it it was good
yeah
but i remember getting chasing women
through the woods great
oh my god but i remember like a trumpet
hey i always heard you coming wait do
you still play trumpet now
no could you if we had one could you
like [ __ ] yeah i could play a little
bit but like it's like that my muscles
are gone so i couldn't play the high
notes and stuff you know
i feel like he's being really modest i
do feel like you're too much i feel like
you're being really modest i think he's
being modest i bet he'd probably kill it
um kippy you want you got anything yeah
have you ever ordered anything other
than pizza from domino's or pizza hut
okay so red bull guy in the midwest
donatos is big okay
have you talked about the bottom we only
had a handful of midwest guys
it's like it's basically like a pup it's
the same thing but like they cut their
pizzas like
like i know exactly what you're talking
about yeah really small grits yeah yeah
yeah um
they're i actually prefer pizza cut like
that yeah okay
um it's real trashy but it's really good
is it trashy
it's very yeah yeah i guess um part of
me thinks it's fancy but i'm trashy so i
don't know
it's it's trash but you know i don't
feel that's like european or something
if i went somewhere and you cut my pizza
differently
that's the [ __ ] you're flexing you're
not just going to eight triangles
you're putting a little flare on it long
strips
no it's trashy because there's a couple
of slices that have no crust
oh there's a bunch of them in the middle
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just get upset
that your pizza doesn't have crust
i call the outsides
muffin throwing his hat in the ring
pop a t-bone huh you guys never ordered
like subs i'd get subs
sub sandwiches hoagies they're hoagies
yeah not
not at like a dominoes at donato's they
had them
domino's has them too but i'm not
ordering them but it's like a restaurant
though like what would you do no no no
it looks just like a papa john's but
okay
it's just only in the midwest maybe
columbus only i don't know it's pretty
big they sell cold sandwiches or they're
all grinders as you would call them
maybe
oh um both they had no no they were hot
they were grinders i don't know what
that o was about
he just got reminded of grinders yeah
[Laughter]
um i feel like papa john's domino's has
good dessert they got that cinnamon
thing
yeah that's trashy though if you're
ordering dessert from domino's pizza
you're garbage i would like to disagree
uh
with the gentleman from bucks county
domino's lava cake
is [ __ ] fantastic i'm not saying it's
not fantastic
it's trashy it's trash if you're
ordering domino's pizza to begin with
i think that's your opinion and uh
you're entitled to it okay he gets so
upset whenever you try to discuss food
with them
now back to this dinardos
are they hiring
uh every year of gatorade with dinner
ah you're garbage man that's your
[ __ ]
that's not a garbage thing that's a
that's a single guy move
you know what i'm saying that's not not
trashy you single guy with a roommate
ask your dad
i do it just like my father before me
and his father before him
he's the way the men in abe family do it
it's not a big deal he's splitting the
blue gay shirt with his
blue glacier with his roommate kenny
nothing on that i mean you fumbled it
i've been fumbling all [ __ ]
episodes got a couple of boats yeah i
mean i got a couple of stickers
and i got a couple of [ __ ] duds i
tried to get out where you wouldn't even
react you just looked at me and moved on
we're all hitting homers but we're
striking
we're striking out i'm trying to go yard
every time by the way i'm not playing
[ __ ] small ball i didn't want to say
anything but fully throughout that ford
f150 line twice
that was good one though that was a good
one i liked it
it kind of worked the second time you
piece of [ __ ]
but but i have i have done that with the
gate i did last night i think
yeah with what with what meal dude i'm a
single guy now bro so you're doing like
slices of pizza and gatorade uh no what
did i [ __ ] make i don't know just
like i'm literally just putting anything
anything you have in the in the [ __ ]
pants no you're not getting off that
easy well jeff for dinner last night it
was
i was trying to make fried rice but i
only had eggs
so i just put rice and eggs like i don't
hate it i gotta be honest
yeah just white rice just white rice
that was a little lemon lime guys i'm
sorry
that's i mean you put some soy sauce or
something in there right i got a little
bit but yeah what i just described
is the domino's lava cake to asian
people like i could not be saying this
[ __ ]
i don't know how i don't know if we have
a lot of asian listeners so i think
you're all right
my girlfriend's filipino she does fried
rice at home [ __ ] fantastic
gotta have some eggs in there tell you
that right now
okay i think we're having a conversation
being friends here
all of a sudden i'm in a haunted house i
can't talk food with you no more i don't
know where we draw the line uh when was
the last time you had a 7-eleven taquito
i've never had one i don't think wow i
would have never
thought that yeah well there aren't that
many 7-elevens and
so in in ohio or where i'm from we
didn't have any what do you got out
there denelly's or something
we just had like whatever like marathon
or whatever the success station was you
know but so when
you you never had a 7-eleven taquito i
don't even know what to kill is
it like it's like the kind of yeah like
the roti thing yeah the rolled
taco burrito deep fried garbage
have you had a marathon hot dog no
but i have had um skyline chili you guys
know what that is
no guy guess what the [ __ ] you know what
that is yeah but that's like
that's like a regional dish not a gas
station hot dog
that's like that's like being like ever
you ever had a 7-eleven pizza it's like
nah but i did have [ __ ] clam chowder
one time
no no no no skylight jelly is guideline
chili it's like
it's like imagine just the pasta from
sabaro
that type of pasta and then you put
chili on it and cheese
that's cincinnati chili yeah but i know
cincinnati spaghetti they call it yeah
that's something i'm dirt balling you're
like you're like a [ __ ] food
encyclopedia
that's franklin's over here or whatever
he was talking about what was the name
of the place
marathon yeah i thought it was a man
this is unraveling quickly
somebody get the big man lollipop i'm
laughing man
i know cincinnati chile is basically
um a meat chili with no a texas chili
with no beans over spaghetti
you've never even been to cincinnati how
do you know that
because i worked with some dirt ball in
philly who was from cincinnati
and he made it for us one time for staff
meal he made it a whole meal male made
yeah it was not good it's so
disrespectful
i love that no i gotta say
the 7-eleven though there's one around
the corner from here they've really
expanded their
go foods that's not bad i don't know if
you've been in there i was in there the
other day with t-bone there was a
chicken porn behind the thing that had
my name on it
i was eyeing up t-bone i'm like dude if
you weren't if toby wasn't there i would
have rolled the dice with it
buffalo mozzarella too huh not bad
um huh ever been in a food eating
contest
uh no i can't eat i can't oh no i lied i
have i have
it was it was i didn't but i didn't i
knew you yes it was in ohio i was in
high school there was like a pizza shop
called uh
[ __ ] uh luke uh
not lou colley that's like nice spot in
kindergarten it was called like
i don't know [ __ ] tony or some [ __ ]
sure that's not what it was called but
it was something like that and they had
this contest we know what italian is
the owner the owner of the pizza place
is that homeless and they're like just
saying it
it's jellies we need this barstool
turned us down we need this
um they had this like pizza eating
contest
and the it's like you get to do so it's
like two teams
and then whoever finishes it first uh
gets it free
and whoever can't finish it has to pay
for both so it's like you do it in teams
oh wait you've done that before that
sounds like a [ __ ] scam to me
it's like a pizza pyramid scheme all she
need is four friends and tell them
did they come to your high school to do
it no no we went to them this is what i
did i did it when i was in high school
with my friends
yeah they didn't like we didn't do this
no they're not going to like talk to us
about abstinence there's a [ __ ] pizza
eating contest guys
not getting laid let's get them to pizza
if you don't win you need 22.50
that's okay wow that's pretty trashy
soph
it's not like i took your blood and i'm
giving you the results you just told us
the story
we're following science here i'm trying
to pull i'm trying to lay a heavy on the
1310 or whatever but you're trying to
dismiss it
yeah all right i got one for you this
was big we did this on the patreon if
you hit the lotto for a million bucks
what car are you buying oh i thought you
guys were gonna buy something say hot
tub
okay that's even trashier than whatever
the car is gonna be
okay okay you wanna stand up a
standalone hot tub might be the
trashiest
no it's not i had them in my family
a little bit man there are three that's
like dude they're three
you gotta get the one where it's like
blue on the inside i'm talking about the
that's all of them that's all it's a
[ __ ] hot dirt it's nice
it's the last time you were in one uh
not that long if i try to get if i get
an airbnb i try to find one with a hot
tub they have a hot tub filter on an
airbnb
oh i know i try to do that wherever i go
did anybody have one growing up that you
were like oh i want that's like the
[ __ ] definition of luxury you know
what
my friend had one but he also had an
above young pool so you're right you
absolutely there we go
yeah yeah stand-alone hot tub people are
above ground pool people yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's the first thing
you're buying a million dollars
yeah are you putting it in your
apartment i mean i'll probably like
relocate
relocate you know make sure the hot tub
is a good spot
i don't know anybody stealing it chain
it up
chain it to the railing that way no one
takes it holy [ __ ] man
so what was the car what kind of car
man i've always had a thing for toyota
celicas you know what that is
they're cool he said it toby pulled a
plug that's always cool
they're cool i'm just stoked he didn't
say race car bed
[ __ ] cool dude they're so cool i just
wait i didn't get one it's not a million
dollar toyota selling i know it's gotta
be used too okay
yeah it's like that's like nine grand i
got that one have you seen the patreon
what the [ __ ]
guys go to patreon.com we'll give phony
a [ __ ] celica
they sell it on facebook marketplace for
eight dollars
[ __ ] nine grand what do you think
we're doing here if we're totties let's
go how much more you say a million
i'm just money's not an option i've had
all the money in the world what kind of
car
yeah it doesn't even you don't have to
go like lambo i mean celica's on the
lower end
i wasn't i wasn't looking for ferrari my
i'll give you my mine is that mine's a
range rover i'd get like a [ __ ] oh
yeah
[Laughter]
i'm buying 2 000 chairs and bosco sticks
oh i'm looking at the proud owner of
bosco's
the majority shareholder of bosco sticks
he choked a day later i want all my
retained earnings
in stick form it's like the segway guy
dying on the segway
uh i mean i got a [ __ ] cool
like looking car there was like there's
a uh
tesla maybe teslas are big let him
answer there's like this i don't know
what's that
acura model that's like orange that's
really cool it's like one of them
is that like no there is no they do they
do it's the one uh
i know what you're talking kenya barris
drives it in one of the shows he's on i
thought it was cool yeah it's like an
rx-8 or something
yeah still orange come on it's gotta be
orange man oh
dude give me that i'm good to go
i mean honestly a trashier celica might
be
the absolute trashiest answer possible
because you think it's nice they're not
gonna like that
you're not even like i wanna buy my
first car it was a chevy loom and a 95
it'll be
it'll be 800 bucks i want to buy that
because it's funny and kitschy you legit
want to buy at 9000. i'm aspiring to
celica
that's the kind of person i am what
would you do to it to the silicon yeah
would you
would you leave it just drive it as is i
think it's perfect
it's beautiful the way it is maybe just
silver two-door what what else do you
want to repaint a picasso
i use that tape thing with the aux cable
you know oh yeah
dude i still don't know you remember the
cassette you put in and the cable comes
due
i still don't know how that technology
works
what was in the tape i know i was like
why did it have to be a tape i can't
explain it
but i don't know what threes better than
that thing
that baffles my mind that thing was
[ __ ] a-okay
yeah but that's not gonna sound nice now
so
what color would it be did you say
silver silver dude i think they only
make them in silver
i have never seen another color no they
have another color these things come
with a d
that and dodge neons only come in that
teal or silver
[ __ ] god any magicians in your family
his dad disappeared
hey she didn't do the away thing that
would have hit a lot
well come on um no but like that kid my
best friend from childhood his brother
was a magician so
he wasn't family but they were magicians
already trying to show you the tricks
yeah he remember he was he would buy
something older buy these tapes he was
older
yeah i've had i've had a kid that i was
friends with his brother was older and a
magician he would corner you
yeah yeah yeah make him watch his dumb
tricks
he's gonna get us weed or not dude i got
a party to get to
how do you make a 20-kind butt appear uh
yeah but no no magicians in my immediate
family
no no no no uh have you ever bought a
pair of sketchers
uh no but i have bought soap shoes which
kind of look like hey
hey
[Laughter]
that you could like jump up and grind a
bench like grind things in life
it's awesome what yeah yeah it's like
like a little like c-shaped plastic
thing in the middle of your shoe so you
could like jump up on this and slide so
you could grind on this if you wanted to
you just grind it it was like it was
like roller blades without the wheels
of where would you wear them like the
school dude yeah and then you could just
like out of nowhere playground yeah when
you were leaving class recess you could
[ __ ]
do a grab and a grind down the handle
that's why i didn't flourish in cross
country
i just showed my shoe all the way to st
brennan's you know that's how i roll and
somehow
a virgin
also into boomi's defense he does all
right now you're a good looking kid good
luck
i don't know i hope you never tell
anybody else this how about the
celebrities well you know anything
anything you're telling us right now
don't ever tell us a lady
i'm proud of celica i'm not gonna let
you have that one i i think it's cool
i don't care if you don't want us to
have it we took it that's ours
man that's i think that might be one of
the top 10
garbage answers he earns
you know in a world explain a trashier
answer than that i really don't have one
because he thinks he thinks it's cool
that's the problem
this wasn't on air but i remember one
time somebody at new york comedy club we
asked our buddy brendan sagalo
uh extremely funny guy loving the death
former guest
loved having him um what he would do
with a million dollars his first answer
was go to disney world that sounds so
genuine though
oh my god but that's up there with that
yeah million dollars
selling i'm on the same level as a guy
from long island that's yeah
that's really such an honor uh uh love
you sags
holy [ __ ] anyone your family ever owned
a convertible
no no no what are your thoughts on cajun
chicken pasta
ever have it cajun chicken no it's the
trashiest meal of all time where do you
get it at garbage places i'm sure
applebee's or somebody has it
it's cajun chicken with like alfredo
sauce
garbage it's more of a midwest thing
moving right along uh growing up did
your family keep magazines in the
bathroom to read
no no no no my my parents tried to
raise me uh classy so we didn't have
stuff like that
bought a tv when you were a kid we
allowed to watch tv yeah we watched tv
yeah yeah
okay anybody ever appear on the local
news for any reason at all
i have appeared in local news oh god for
[Laughter]
beatboxing
like define the laws of physics at this
point
there wasn't much going on you know in
the community and
i was beatboxing like there was a lot
going on in my neighborhood either
i ended up on channel three spitting
rhymes
they had a little newspaper already
called me on the columbus dispatch it
was this
highlight of my life really wearing
squeezy shoes
[Laughter]
let me see your butthole or let me have
that donut it's weird and weird oh
god wait so beep out you're a beat boxer
like i'm not gonna ask you to do it yeah
i just did it for fun like a little bit
when i was a kid because i liked music
i'm like super into music
did you do it in front of people like
would you be doing this at parties
this is worse than the magic
he's like nah no magicians i am a hell
of a beat box
um oh who was the
no not i didn't have like a guy there
was someone
or
so when we were there was somebody that
hit big at that only if your mother knew
yeah who was that i thought it was like
rizzo or something like that no
yeah [ __ ] i know you're talking about
yeah if your mother only knew yeah
anyways so like uh yeah i would just
like you know i would do that and then
and then i don't i i
don't do that where you go
i got school and stuff with my friends
and then like we're gonna you're like
hanging out
like you know like near some lockers in
the middle of school like lunch table
you guys get like a beat going and you
go in
and and you and all right i gotta follow
i gotta follow up
do you know any of the lyrics from the
rap battles from eight mile
no no i never watched it and is this all
asian kids is this asian kids and white
kids
no asian kids here so it's you and a
bunch of whites uh asian kid beatboxing
and a bunch of white supermarkets
rapping
it's it's it's truly um yeah but word
got out and the columbus ditch was like
dispatch
makes funny noises they didn't know what
to do they're like i've never seen you
but they're just talking about my asian
face
i've never seen anyone like you before
word got out this kid would know dad's a
real dork
that's the word that got out word got
out
anyway i guess the word got out that he
said that earnestly
i guess word got out you know you can't
deny
talent they say be undeniable they gave
me the keys to the city wait a minute i
got a key to huncle barrier what was the
name of your town
high line you're like can't remember
anything i've told you
we're idiots look at the giggles we've
been having a good time here i hope you
folks are enjoying this because i'm
having a blast
uh when was the last time you took the
mega man i'm not though stop but
we're not going i'm moving on from the
beatboxing thing would you do it
uh like did you put on shows
columbus tribune doesn't reach out if
you're not showing off
okay i did it at like the talent show
the school talent show once like
sophomore year but like i didn't like
go do it club or something i didn't like
i wasn't like handing out flyers
yo come to my show this is live at st
brendan's like
were you dressing the part what was your
style in high school would you say like
urban outfitters [ __ ] you know like i
just i really liked music so i had a lot
of
shirts with like headphones on them and
stuff you know
um yeah just trying to be cool well you
failed
i'm sorry i hate to break it to you 15
years later but you missed the boat
i'm sad
well you failed well i mean he's like
one of the coolest kids i know now look
at him yeah
don't tell anybody in brooklyn anything
about it they're not going to let you
know this you cannot get out
yeah i don't think we have big broken
listeners either we're
more columbus ohio
people aren't listening to this and
going to matchless man oh
[ __ ] my head hurts i'm literally i've
said this a bunch like i don't know what
to do
this is insane this is insanity
cool kid you dress cool nice pea coat
it's not in the village you were even
put together you got cool friends you do
the cool shows
good with the ladies my god i had no
idea
that article's probably still in line
somewhere oh yeah
probably we're gonna find out
uh ever have to call 9-1-1 on a family
member no
no okay all right sorry to insult you um
you might have been beatboxing too late
you just called bee boxing beatbox
um jesus christ have you ever
have you ever worn a hard rock cafe
t-shirt
yeah but um hard rock cafe t-shirts are
like cool in japan
so uh it's different i think you're
gonna say in columbus
no no they're like cool i'll give that
to you a different culture you didn't
live in japan no i didn't
i was doing it in ohio but but it was
like if you go to tokyo you see people
wearing it like in a very cool way
so there is that was a part of that
absolutely not but
was i part of that movement
was i a part of that no in fact i wasn't
so you were doing it like a [ __ ] ohio
hillbilly wearing a hard rock cafe did
you guys do you guys know what the salty
dog cafe is
it's buddy yeah not a salty dog a lot of
kids at my high school would wear
t-shirts is it a real place i think so
outer banks or something like a
margaritaville but like kids from a high
school would go but it's like a clothing
line at this point yeah they would go
there it's like myrtle beach area or
wherever for the spring break they would
always wear it back so
yeah that was like i guess that was the
equivalent
for sure for sure man hmm
you ever call anybody mate no no
say cheers instead of thank you uh no
no have you ever gone to an
all-inclusive resort
uh yes yes a couple of times when yeah
like recently
yeah a couple couple years ago okay
moving my family mexico
cancun it was nice okay yeah we're not
talking about sandals or hedonism or
anything like that
no no no family good time still never
still trashy but sure
yeah i did buy like
actually i lied but once before that in
2013 i went to costa rica
that was like an all-inclusive trip and
i bought it off a groupon i don't know
if that counts who'd you go there
yeah no that counts so we were looking
forward i don't know if this guy's but
the absolute tragedy has answered
your question i forgot i did that plays
it off on the family vacation
[ __ ] guy could you believe this guy
he's just like a high school friend from
ohio
who should go to groupon beach with
[Laughter]
um it rained all week so it was not a
good time
that's why i was on groups you need
someone to come sit in a hotel room for
four days
good thing i brought my trumpet we
didn't go
uh do you have an outgoing message on
your voicemail
uh no not now i don't think what does it
say
you've reached the number this is just
like it's automatically i don't think
okay have you ever had a ring back
tone like oh yeah yeah but i mean you
had that was the thing back in the early
like 2000s you got you did what i did
you just
you did the the [ __ ] verizon like
that
i didn't have any i just had a regular
call
[Laughter]
um i did i was like one of those kids
who like found it's like in 2008 i
like found this like program where you
could like download your own songs and
like
because back then you have to buy it off
the verizon store or
you have to have this like yeah i
remember the people that had that i was
that that might as well be nasty
i mean i had i went through the whole
like emo face i had like fall out boy
and [ __ ] on there you know sure hey
tight pants you know how it is or not
okay no
for sure i never i was a little older
for that emo phase
uh the kids you like you know your age
you know a few years younger in school
are really hit
it was more the 50 cent eminem phase
let's talk about injuries sustained as a
child
um okay this is really embarrassing but
so i played wait more so than everything
you thought was
more than the last time this might top
celica
well i don't know so this is it's not
really trashy i just think i'm weak i
i played lacrosse from fourth grade to
seventh grade i had to quit in seventh
grade because
that's when all my white friends went
through puberty yeah and i stayed the
same size and then they just got [ __ ]
fully sized you know i cannot play a
sport with these men
yeah um but the seventh grade was the
last try i played because like uh
this is when all this was happening but
during prague lacrosse practice
this is when like you know we're just
dudes [ __ ] around like we would prank
each other and like table topping was in
remember table topping table tapping is
when like a
so if i if i were to oh neil behind you
and push over yeah so one friend kneels
behind you one person puts you over
right man nothing hurts more than that
i did that it was the embarrassment of
it yes nobody ever got hurt
i broke my arm at lacrosse practice
because somebody
did that to me and then that kid thought
i was gonna sue him or something
and so he was like really scared
[Laughter]
uh i guess you weren't a milk with
dinner kind of kid growing up no
no no no no no good i couldn't get a lot
of career i have uh lactose i'm lactose
intolerant really yes
you know that found that i was like a
lot of asians are yeah after a certain
age
really yeah that's like that's like
that's our weakness
[Laughter]
um holy [ __ ] i guess passport's out of
the question how old are you got your
passport
yeah international yeah i'm very well
traveled i would say
what was the last country you went to uh
italy nice where did you go what was
this
last thanksgiving for uh i always travel
during thanksgiving because my fame
doesn't do thanksgiving and then
my girlfriend at the time she was also
from an immigrant family she doesn't
really do thanksgiving so we always
travel during thanksgiving so
what's italy a good time what's good
where in italy did you go that's nice
like rome florence uh naples uh milan
in four days very nice
[Laughter]
uh when was the last time you cashed in
change and how much was it for
cashed in change
uh tough in new york there's not a lot
of calling stars well i used to like
collect
i i still like that way this is
basically whatever it's coming out is
next i don't know i used to like a
gatorade bottle
yeah you just put change in there back
when like cash was more common and i
feel like now everything's been on [ __ ]
uh so i did all through college and when
i graduated i went to coinstar or like
td bank would do it for yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they were
they got caught with their hand in the
cookie jar yeah they stopped doing it
oh i i think i didn't hear about that
but last time i did it it was a lot i
was like 80 bucks or something like that
yeah that was a good day uh brush your
teeth in the shower
100 but i've got a toothbrush so am i
garbage i don't know
i don't know yeah bro yeah
you said that you said that like a
doctor trying to
yeah what about peeing in the shower how
do you feel about that you got you gotta
be in the shower yeah
i don't know it's my life's listening
yeah i don't actually i got i got into
it late
like in my 20s i didn't do it for a long
time i didn't i think i'd grow up doing
it but like i
had heard about it i've been peeing in
the shower as far as i can remember yeah
i was i was masturbating in the shower
before i was peeing in the shower does
that make sense i like wet work
yeah you know hey i'm with it
do you still masturbate in the shower no
because we have an apartment i had this
incident
where like well that was an incident
it's just like when you masturbate in
the shower
the jizz gets all cut and caught in the
drain and like when i was younger like
i just thought it went down so i don't
think i never clean you gotta put a
second pair of eyes on it after you get
out how much are you jerking off in
there like it was
back then like every day you might as
well you're like [ __ ] in there i mean
he was playing the trumpet for god's
sake
kids got to get some sleep i feel like
rope are you throwing
but it was my mom's shower it was the
shower in her room
and like you're just dumping clips in
your mouth it was just why were you
showing in your mom's bathroom
because it was a nicer shower but hold
on you had two showers in the house
we had two yeah folks that's pretty
classy what do you got
we got one tough break fatso
[Laughter]
let me tell you that chair was a dirty
little
fab full his whole family's jerking off
in the shower oh the foal is just
slinging skyline chili right
his whole family listens too ah shout
outs to the follies but uh my
one day was like one day i went in there
i noticed it like it wasn't nearly as
sticky and i
realized my mom had cleaned it and i was
like oh that was jizz the whole time
and so i was like never again so that's
when i stop stop doing that
and poor [ __ ] between you and
your sister what's the [ __ ]
yeah i mean i don't know who she's more
disappointed
to be honest with you the one having sex
with the people at least
at least someone else is involved in the
up after world oh man
you're like you should have moved to
south carolina with your dad give you
two bozos the house
uh how do you clean a public toilet seat
i just
uh well i wipe it down and i put toilet
paper like a [ __ ] gentleman that's
the way to do it
it's not bad are there other ways to do
it how do you guys [ __ ] do it you
don't want to know how full
you use your [ __ ] hoodie
that's very funny and gross foley's is
worse
fully hit him with it what i we haven't
talked about this in a couple of months
sure what i do if i go into now i make
sure it's a respect somewhat respectful
respect why is this word coming up
i make sure it's you know somewhat clean
there's like poop and [ __ ] in there i'll
just go to the next one
obviously so it's a somewhat clean
toilet what i'll do
is i'll flush the toilet a bunch of
times let the water go down get it clean
yeah then i'll take a paper towel or
some some toilet paper
i'll dab it in the water in the toilet
and then wipe the seat and then raise it
again
that's like that's clean fresh water no
it's like mountain
how dare you it's like you're all right
thank you how dare you pulling spring
how dare you call that freshwater it
flushes down
into a bowl where random people [ __ ] and
piss
wow wow wow what do you what are you
okay let me ask you this
like scientifically what do you think is
happening oh i like this like scientific
13
10 minutes what are you really
okay all right germ wise i don't know
but it feels cleaner to me okay
i'm not just sitting down on people's pp
for sure yeah that is that is better
than doing this so
yeah who does that
um how many fast and furious movies have
you seen oh not a lot like three
yeah it's okay i mean you could you
could be blind and still catch three of
them mean they've been out for 15
20 years it's so aggro the advertising
if it stumbles across tbs on a saturday
those things are everywhere daddy-o ah
you ever snap instead of clap uh only
when it's appropriate
you know when would that be appropriate
like like you're doing it like
ironically or whatever
you know like some poetry somebody says
something
mic drop okay ironically ironically i'm
sure
yes all right fair enough hmm
like i'm being [ __ ] interrogated for
some weird crime for wanting a celica
you put up a lot of red flags yeah huh
everyone a pair of duck boots
see that again duck boots what are duck
boots d-u-c-k
yeah duck boots i don't know what they
are they're winter boots but they have
like the
the plastic on on the on the on the on
the bottom of them
google duck boots how do you don't know
a northeastern l.l bean style boot
like leather on top no
no no okay i feel like those are classy
though
maybe they are that's those are classic
i didn't say they weren't a lot of my
friends 159 at llb
that's a classy book i didn't say they
weren't i just asked him if he ever
owned a picture i i think i've wanted it
if it was a size 11. no i've never i've
never owned one
okay all right i think i only got one or
two more than we can do some patreon
ones yeah um hmm
yeah that's it what growing up shoes in
the house or no shoes in the house no
shoes
no shoes you do that now right you can't
wear shoes in your new york apartment
did your mom run a tight ship the place
was nice and clean spotless
yeah yeah she was a good good cleaning
lady good cook
yes good cook yep yep um
yeah all right i got i got two we gotta
get two and then we gotta go let's get
out i got two from patreon guys so when
you join the patreon we will ask your
garbage questions
uh it's one of the ways to guarantee it
uh otherwise we just get so many um
coming in and stuff like that it's the
best way to do it
so this is from kristen on the patreon
you get a frozen pizza i put this
came up perfectly you get a frozen pizza
circle frozen pizza yes yes
uh normally how do you cut it you cut it
in four
six eight slices eight
you go all eight i do eight yeah by
yourself and your apartment
uh well you know i went
and your mom cleans it up uh well i used
to live with somebody so you know it's
eight so we can all share
now i think that behavior just kind of
i'm still kind of used to it yeah
i'm a four guy that's really you just
eat the like with the hand
yeah just like a bigger slice of pizza
well let me ask you i'm eating the pizza
i don't know i don't care how many times
do you own a pizza slicer roller
no no no no so it's okay using a knife
so that's where i could see where the
where the less cuts would come in what
with the knife
with the knife yeah unless you have if
you have a pizza roller you should be
you know you got a pizza roller
what got one on me
kidding me the pizza roll i got a pizza
roller i have tongs i got the [ __ ]
whole nine yards i mean
so do you fold it if it's four like i
don't understand like the functionality
of
the before no wait so like a circle
pizza yeah cd4
not like a not like a full size like a
regular frozen pizza i don't know
you two never sounded stupider well i
don't know what he does
can you fold it he got a 13 10.
yeah so it would be like you know
whatever this big yeah you would go
one two and it would just be like a
bigger typically the crust is a little
thicker right crunchier it's not soggy
right right right you know i guess you
know
you're just i'm not an engineer get your
dad on the phone
his roommate's on the phone it's me
kenny the [ __ ] are you
terry your son's on the phone again
i don't know where he is but he wants to
give you a smack when he sees you
that kind of makes me sad a little bit
somebody somebody cutting up a pizza in
their apartment by themselves
it's eight slices hoping seven more
people come
they'll be here that's an invitation oh
man just in case
just in case anyone shows up dinner
party for one
that's just me i just saw me in his
apartment
just slicing up the pizza oh god just
eat the whole
thing it's one don't even slice it yeah
bite into it um all right this is from
evan mcfarlane which is a [ __ ] home
another question
did your parents start charging rent
almost immediately after graduating high
school
because i had those friends that
immediately got a rent bill due on like
june 1st
yeah man and it's like what are we doing
thank god patty i love you never in a
million years would i
you would have had to chase me oh yeah
no no no no no yeah i don't think my
parents would
do that i mean they would now maybe but
i never lived with them after after high
school so
after high school i guess you were in
new york new york and then
not going back to [ __ ] columbus so
when did you graduate from nyu 2012
2012 and then you stay you were here
from that from then on yeah when'd you
start doing comedy
2014. oh you did okay yeah so that was
right after we got here
yeah yeah yeah so um they didn't have to
go through that but that that must be
like
have your parents offer that that would
be like an awkward [ __ ] conversation
i had an even awkwarder conversation
my my stepdad has like a rental property
that when i was like 25 i don't know
five or something i was like convinced
i'm like hey let us rent it you know
what i mean me and my buddy
we'll rent it and uh he [ __ ] took a
security deposit and we kind of did
trash it but he ended up keeping the
security oh
wow what a day and i had to move back
into his house
i was like i was like wait and i'm like
well i'm like by law he's got to give it
to me within 30 days my mom's like shut
up
you are not getting that by law like
i'll take them to court
over my share of 1200 bucks i was ready
to risk it all
you owe me 350. yeah we're trash we are
trash yeah my parents would have never
done that and i did live at my parents
at you know after 18. you lived with
your parents a couple of years ago
like after 18 you're 45. i met you you
were living at your parents
there's a couple of valleys in the story
of that by the way isn't it your
birthday
me no when's your birthday uh it's at
the end of the month later
this month sorry i thought it was this
week i apologize okay thank you i
thought you could you get me something
what the [ __ ] you asking for i gave you
this
taking those cards i mean i have i mean
within the first four minutes of this
episode i had all i needed to have
i mean to draw my conclusions i'm
stunned
i really on my way here i was like i
wonder if they've had a classy guest i
might be their first classy guest i was
so wrong
oh what made you think because i was
listening to your other guests and
they're doing like all these really like
trashy garbage like stuff that i was
saying this one's this one's up there
yeah yeah i don't know
it's our show we're telling you it's
great i've gotta hunt this
this is our 100th episode wow if there
was a if there was a champions week or
whatever it is
yeah you're coming back if there was
sweeps
it's going to be you and ken jennings i
don't know my god you're coming yeah
the celica the grandmom the dad leaving
listen i know you're i know you're a
super funny guy but i was worried this
was going to be
not boring but i i just i thought you
were
i'm not gonna lie i was also worried as
well not boring but i was just like oh i
wonder like if i could mess with him you
know what i'm saying
i thought you were going to be so classy
that like yeah i thought you were going
to be like very like yeah kind of
bland not bland but like i i know it's
coming off wrong
dude i had no i don't think you were
going to be true i didn't think you were
gonna be
pure garbage oh well that's yeah i
thought you were gonna be like no we
never you need to know that
you're garbage you need to know you're
cool as [ __ ] now i'll give you that but
you
yikes yeah this is before we let you go
let's let's
let's do this okay all right what's the
apartment like now
oh it's nice well really because it's
furnished so like why is it furnished
because i was living my girlfriend
we were taking a break so i she's got
the place i lived at
and then i didn't want to buy a bed and
stuff so oh that makes sense
because i'm not going to because because
the lease on this apartment uh that my
girlfriend i lived at is still
you know active till june so it's like
i'm not going to buy furniture until we
know we're doing so
did you guys buy all that furniture
together at the place you bought most of
it so
okay um but anyways this new place is um
oh my god he's got your what you got
your what you got your wallet ten years
will be in mexico
holy [ __ ] you got your walking papers
from a relationship on how to buy a
furnished
you get a furnished apartment yeah
that's 90s divorce
dad is it by the airport where do you
live
what part of staten island is it it is
by a bridge but uh
this is crazy i guess i never really
looked into myself that's the thing like
as
corny as it sounds that's part of that's
the show people are like oh [ __ ]
i never even put all of these stories
together furnished apartments
isn't classy either you know that right
i mean this i mean this place is like
you know
it can be i don't care it's got plans
somebody else was farting on that couch
that's true probably you at some point
i was in there oh man
um yeah i mean it's amazing it's that's
like a thing i'll be thinking about that
for a while because i swear to god like
up until like 2010 i had that as my
computer background you know what i'm
saying like for me
i asked you if you got a million dollars
what's the first
what kind of car would you but you said
a toyota selling i said hot tub but then
i said
oh my god i forgot about that jesus um i
was proud of it
dude this is 4 900 bucks we literally
make them we
literally we literally make that buy
this patreon
if we get i think we need like literally
two more five dollar patreon members and
we'll buy you i'll buy you a [ __ ]
celica
holy [ __ ] that's the actual one you want
right there
that's that's it the baby girl there it
is i was thinking of the older one this
is no no the new one's cool
see that's not no it's no no that's
worse the older one's cool
no [ __ ] [ __ ] the old ones are like it's
got like it comes in blue and [ __ ] no no
no no no no no
this one's
you know that car is shitty you can see
the guy's shadow with the
guys yeah yeah that's a that's an
apartment complex gt though that's a
nice one
[Laughter]
it comes with a copy of [ __ ] too fast
too furious
everybody fantastic thank you so much
100 garbage
dude this is so much fun thank you for
having me this was so great we got it
great we love the
absolutely amazing thing you want the
folks to know out there
what anything you want to plug go right
down the focus on my life
anything you want the folks out there to
know oh you want to
get your head on straight uh yo check
out my uh podcast called asian.edu yes
very funny
all the podcast platforms and then
follow me on instagram at the fumio
that's t-h-e-f-u-m-i-a-b-e yeah guys
check him out very funny comedian check
him out
old pal of ours kip uh as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and patreon.com get that bonus content
baby get in we're having a good time
uh thank you to everybody who bought the
[ __ ] cards the response was
way greater than we had [ __ ]
anticipated thank you so much and also
at kevin ryan comedy on all social media
i gotta go outside and have a smoke
after this thank you
guys we love you and we'll see you next
week
gang real quick before you check out
hang on a second i want to talk to you
one more time about the stereo app
we're having a great time over there
what do you got an android or you got an
iphone
it's free download it yeah guys uh use
the link in the description
of this show it's www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley when you sign
up using that link we get to wet our
beaks a little bit it's a good time a
lot of good shows on there we're there
every thursday having fun
maybe a couple cocktails uh-oh see you
there